another check  and how is he getting his knights back  he needs to really hurry now that black  pawn is so close  and some of the squares the white  knights want to use to retreat they are  covered  i guess he has to use the uh f4 knight  and uh  plank it on the b4 square or the c1  square  and that way he has  the past alice the a pawn under control  and he gives a check  um richard the problem with him is we  can never guess his moves  he's always going to do what we least  expect to always what uh the opponent at  least expects  and right now where is gary gonna try  and hide the black king  okay it goes back where it came from oh  this is the second time we've seen this  position and  third time it's a draw  it is a draw richard reporter and anish  geary one uh two of the favorites in the  tournaments they finish with a drool